wild 1941 the bootleg can't show sitting
in front of me we have got the very
beautiful WWE diva she is man you're
more pretty in real life like I see you
on TV all the time
I follow you on the gram we got even
Murray in the building how you doing I'm
really good are you excited for
Wrestlemania we were in the bear oh you
from the bank who's your favorite Bay
Area rapper of all time so many I'm a
huge Tupac Sam yeah but people don't
know Tupac like like a lot of his early
like he's literally 40 maybe
Marni of course oh wow Andre Nikitina
see see she's a nut she knows her
underground ish as well are you a
Raiders fan or an Anderson or neither or
neither you know I'm really a giant oh
so whose baseball family Sophia I
respect it then you guys just won the
World Series last exactly ring three
rings and what's not three and five so
wrestle but this is your second wrestle
me
second WrestleMania I feel like the
Divas division is growing a lot
especially like I always say like NXT
they've really given like divas a lot of
love and then recently there was like a
hashtag that was on Twitter I think was
like divas what was it gif divas a
change how do you feel about I guess the
difference between how NHD is given
divas a lot more time and as opposed to
like raw where I feel like it's it's
really a lot more story storyline based
and not necessarily match based you know
I really think like now's the time for
the Divas I mean obviously the fans
spoke out Internet the wonderful thing
but like you said I mean it's it's doing
something it's made a lot of noise and
you know in the past few weeks you can
see on on rod stuff like that our
segments are getting will do it longer I
feel like the fans you know they just
they want to see the demons they want to
see a little bit more invested in them
and I've seen nothing wrong with that
because we're just as capable so I think
now is the time 2015 it's going to be up
you spoke about the internet being good
at times now with someone as beautiful
as yourself I can only imagine how
creepy your inbox on Instagram for me I
mean how many I mean do you get like
what what are your DMS look like some
like you just random freak ball DMS on
the gram or on Twitter or like you know
what I'm I don't even look of ideas
you don't write [__] your Pikul Blaine
probably best I think so I probably hire
an assistant to go under tight it's like
clear mountain what is the weirdest fan
interaction you had has there been like
a situation where you've had a situation
where you gotta get your buff husband to
be somebody um you know what everything
so far that I've encountered awesome
everyone's been super
I had my first wizard world oh yeah okay
the fan love oh my gosh I like I can't
think the red nations I'm not because
they've supported me from day one it's
been a cookie to myself so I'm recently
back in the ring trained on my butt off
so that mom and then another thing I
wanted to ask you I know that a lot of I
mean obviously we first saw you from
from the W neva show on on the network a
lot of times reality shows the little
stage did you really have the balls to
just say you know what I'm not gonna go
blonde I'm gonna dye my hair red was
that something that really happened that
is 100% true I just couldn't do it
you're not gonna find a blonde I mean I
Mexico Cali and I tried to be blond in
high school it wasn't a good look for me
like I've already done this I've done
that I just there was no way that I was
really gonna find them and rock it you
know so I mean that's what's in them but
thinking about you know boss football
look that was red nation it has worked
out for you as far as one one plus or
minus main on TV show us your love life
is probably don't got married follow
your husband on Instagram you dance me
feel like a
a puny bastard every time I like I sweat
looking at that guy's Instagram like
this guy is a monster how was the
married life going it's amazing I mean I
am so lucky I am I'm married to my best
friend he's the biggest partner and yeah
Thai guy like seriously he's he's a no
home boy I watched it I bought Instagram
because I'm skinny fat I call myself
skinny fat and obviously I matter of
fact I have a belly because I don't like
oh I play a lot of video games and they
do our food and I'm your every time I'm
on the rock and your husband when I
swallow the gram like number watch the
WB network but anyway yo are you are you
what are you what is your role in
WrestleMania this year WrestleMania I'm
gonna do with my family enjoying the
show your family's in town so you're
gonna just have a good time enjoy the
show exactly I'm really looking for the
rock enrollments
please we need some predictions from you
okay he's gonna walk away with the time
then at the end of the night because you
know there's a wild card in their name
Seth Rollins but potentially you're here
to put money on you're in Vegas right
now Roman reigns I am too and then I'm
gonna take a break
you love break I love bread and I'm just
at the I'm a huge fan
his entire thing going on yes great way
all right well Eva Marie I look forward
to seeing you in the ring more I hope
are you're like healthy now you're good
I'm good
you're good to go you're coming back so
when I get that title you got to get the
title yeah you got we go ahead and just
change the straps make them red you got
to do that and that would be a lot more
fly
you gotta put some Bay Area swag on it
come on yes and when you get it you got
to have like a four year to sort of
bring you to the ring next year Russell
may know or or you could put the rest of
the world at the Andre Nikitina Eva
Marie appreciate your time sweetie thank
you so much yeah